oh there they are look they're cute too
right i'm gonna hit like a cute song oh
boy
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we open up season 16 with jimmy
kimmel he's the emmy award-winning elder
statesman of late night catch jimmy
kimmel live weeknights 11 35 10 35
central on abc he also executive
produced once upon a time in queens a
four-part documentary on the 86 mets
available now on espn plus jimmy kimmel
welcome to the show thank you sean it's
great to be here i brought you a gift
because i know what you need is more hot
sauce this is my favorite hot sauce
catino so that's for you
not that you need more hot sauce but
it's a tasty it's not really a hot hot
sauce and let me tell you something
flavorful maybe you don't know this but
jacob gattino a mutual friend of ours
right hot sauce world he actually made
our first ever hot one sauce he told me
that generally speaking how are you
around the spicy stuff i'm pretty good
with it i like spicy stuff i was um you
know when i was in high school i i
wasn't quite that adventurous so
we go to this place called billy's west
in las vegas i grew up in vegas me and
my friend tommy we'd get a 50 wings a
piece and he'd get him extra hot i'd get
my medium
and one night we bought them we went
home we're eating them we're drunk of
course i'm going gosh mine are really
really hotter than usual he's like yeah
mine would feel hot at all and i think
we got through like half of the bucket
each before we realized we had each
other's buckets well you're ready to
relive that trauma time i'm ready i'm
ready i think i'm ready i don't know
[Music]
i'd rather drink this whole bottle of
hot sauce than drink milk it's
disgusting to me i'm also gonna try to
do it without the water okay because i
know matt damon
drank a lot of water and
i just i'm part of why i'm here is to
teach him a lot there we go there we go
okay
tasting
[Music]
that's a nice start
so i want to start with your latest
project once upon a time in queens would
you describe as a must-see story of a
team at a time whose antics and even
existence now seem unimaginable beyond
being a mets fan in the team winning a
world series what is it that you find
most compelling or everlasting about
that particular clubhouse this is a
group of crazy people this was a group
of i mean the guys who got four fights
this team got in four on field fights in
one season which is unusual this is a
team that was popping pills and doing
all sorts of drugs and even more so it's
like new york in the mid-80s and what
that was like and it seemed like people
were having a lot of fun and then do you
have an all-time favorite jimmy kimmel
fantasy baseball moment because between
having vin scully announce one of your
celebrity softball game homers and then
facing mets pitcher pedro estacio for
man show [ __ ] oh that's right i did
yeah you have some big ticket items in
the bucket list oh boy yeah i've had a
lot of um
i have to say hitting that home run on
espn and that softball game
was
top five greatest things ever to happen
to me and i've showed that clip and i
would love it if you show that clip
right now i've showed that clip
no less than 150 times on my show well
you know maybe you can use your clout in
the disney family here to help us
license the clip now that clip will be
granted free
not just to you but anyone wants to use
it
against one of the great softball
pitchers in the game as usual he was
always guilty of talking too much before
he actually had it
but he's a little nervous considering
this there's a long fly ball the deep
right center
[Music]
oh i have this sauce at my house and
it's good
so i'm really drawn to your small market
radio war stories which to me are like
the true broadcasters corollary it's
like the comedian's comedy circuit
early in your career can you give me one
firing from a radio station that you
look back on and agree was totally
justified
and then another one that you would say
that you would regard as bs even to this
day
none of them were totally justified um
all of them were somewhat justified but
still i can't believe and this is the
sort of thing that keeps me up at night
i i think about
how hard i was working and like what i
was doing which was
not particularly polished but pretty
good and the fact that i kept getting
fired over and over again and i can only
come to one conclusion it's that i did
not have any common sense when it came
to how to get along with your boss with
your superior
one time i had this boss named mark todd
at krq in tucson arizona and there was a
hot dog sitting out somewhere so we took
it and we shoved it in his desk and we
closed the drawer of the desk the next
day um we're in his office and we see
the hot dog in the garbage and we wait
till he goes out and we take the hot dog
and we put it in like another drawer in
it and we just kept going on and on for
like 11 days
at night we actually pushed up the
ceiling tiles and climbed over the wall
into his office which was locked i got
on his desk and the desk collapsed under
my weight the whole bookshelf came down
the office was absolutely destroyed this
is our boss completely destroyed and uh
we're like oh [ __ ] so we just kind of
walked out the door and left and left it
like that he came into work he's like
what was he quick in my room
still isn't he probably to this day
doesn't know what happened but now he
does
[Music]
hops this is no relation to no not
dehoff okay
you're getting a little harder
yeah that's good too though tastes good
so from building out a custom pizza oven
to an immersion circulator for sous vide
cooking it's clear that you have an
obvious affinity for food what's the
best home cooking lesson that you've
ever learned about making pizza at home
from chris bianco and do you like wise
have something that you've picked up on
the art of grilling from adam perry lane
as chris bianco goes and as far as uh
making pizza goes
it's almost impos what chris does is
magical it's like
you know you could he could train you
for a month and you still won't be able
to do it you know but um from him i
learned that
um it's better to be sparing with
ingredients like you know i remember as
a kid like ordering extra cheese on the
pizza and of course yeah of course i
want the extra cheese but the truth of
the matter is the best pizza
has just the right amount of sauce and
just the right amount of cheese on it if
you put too much the dough doesn't get
cooked properly so you need to have
the real estate needs to be arranged in
a nice way
and from adam
um i've learned a lot of different
things about meat one of them is that
you can take a baseball bat and you can
pound the steak mercilessly and then
throw it on the grill and it's gonna
probably taste better oh and a little
cathartic as well yeah for sure
[Music]
i make a nice chicken wing myself
yeah talking me through it
what i do is i make a combination of hot
sauce barbecue sauce
a blue cheese dressing i'll smoke the
wings in my smoker and then i finish
them on the grill to crisp them up
that's a big hit on super bowl sundae
do you remember at what point you fell
in love with the prank call like how far
back does it go and do you have any
memory of your first successful one
yeah um in fact i have tapes of uh being
like 10 years old and making prank calls
with my best friend clito who's now my
band leader on my show khalido carried
on a full sexual relationship with an
adult british man pretending to be a
woman for like a month's time
he'd say oh meet me at the flamingo i'm
going to be at the barn then this poor
guy would go show up thing and it worked
well for us
and then what was it like to fly out to
detroit for a weekend and shoot crank
anchors with eminem i read that he he
reached out because he had to be on the
show because he loved it he did yeah he
loved the show and um we went and
recorded at his studio with him which
was a lot of fun and this is like
ah gosh i don't know what year i think i
guess it's like maybe like 2001 or
something
and um you know at the time we thought
maybe he was a scary character but he
was very nice and really into it he
loved the show and in fact he used our
crank anchors puppets in a music video
that he did right yeah that was pretty
great oh richard pryor was a fan of
crank anchors whoa when he was toward
the end of his life and he was very ill
and his wife called us and said richard
is a big fan of the show and he wants
um to know if you have any more episodes
that he can watch and we've been working
on the next season and so we sent him
all the rough cuts of our our crank
calls which he watched and apparently
enjoyed and that for me was i mean
that's awesome that's about as good as
it gets
[Music]
okay all right
yeah that's a little step up
[Music]
mm-hmm good though
are you guys taking it easy on me or uh
is matt damon just as big a wuss
as i thought he was
dropping him
all right jimmy we have a recruiting
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context correct
so we'll pull up the picture on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story oh
the don tommy lasorda oh man i've had so
many funny experiences with tommy
lasorda one time i was at a spring
training game tommy was coaching but
tommy was sound asleep in a folding
chair on the field and he's like this
he's snoring
and anytime somebody would have him
the
third base coach joe moffitano would
give him an elbow and tommy when he woke
up he was already cursing he'd go like
this god damn it you [ __ ] here
and then he told us about going through
you son of a [ __ ]
it was unbelievable and then there was
that time that you actually tried out
for the dodgers i did we tried out for
the dodgers adam carolla and i and uh we
didn't make the team you'll be shocked
to learn but
we had a great day and i kept i think we
kept saying to tommy like we're going to
go out there and give 110 percent
there's no drove him insane
he's like yeah there's no such thing as
a hunter just a hundred percent like ah
we like to crank it up to 110
and then what is the key to making the
perfect simple weeknight marinara i
don't know why i didn't realize this
sooner but it's to have great tomatoes
and the best tomatoes are bianca
dinapoli canned tomatoes they are the
best tomatoes and um
chris bianco grows them california new
york times agreed they did they raided
all the tomatoes and they said they're
the best but you want to do
it's pretty simple you get a little bit
of olive oil you crush some garlic
cloves you get them till they're just
golden you remove them from the olive
oil you throw the tomatoes in you bring
it to a boil you put a little bit of
salt in set it to simmer you throw some
basil in wait a half hour you got a
great meal
[Music]
pretty good nice work honduras
so i know that you've long dreamed of
having a late night show and i was
tickled to read that your first ever car
and a suzu eye maker actually had the
vanity plates late night yeah i think
that late night show hosts they have
such a unique vantage point into the
changing face of celebrity culture and
what ways has the nature of famous
people coming into due press and what
ways do you think it's changed the most
from when you started to now huh
interesting well for me i know a lot of
things have changed like
you know i used to have terrible guests
[Laughter]
for the most part i mean i get like i
wouldn't even get jill millionaire i'd
get like the third the girl he rejected
fourth on the show you know so um
but
it's a little bit competitive with the
other shows because you want to get
these guests first but we've worked out
such an arrangement now that it's like
all right you get jennifer aniston first
this time next time we'll swap you know
or whoever it is and um i think it's for
a friendlier environment than maybe it
used to be i think part of that is
probably because most people don't watch
our shows at 11 35 they watch them
online whenever they feel like it so you
don't have to really choose between
shows you can watch all of them yeah
i've heard you say something kind of
interesting about how like when the idea
of that competition gets brought up how
you think about when you were working at
radio and like these smaller markets how
that was much more competitive than what
you'd think of in like the late night
wars
guys yeah yeah because you can only
listen to one radio show driving to work
every day at a time you can't listen to
two but now you can you know and then
you were on to youtube really early like
way before any other of these uh late
night show hosts yeah after we made this
video i'm [ __ ] matt damon right
people started posting it on their
youtube channels and it was getting
millions many like tens
100 million views something like that
some people
would like add stuff to it or they
didn't i didn't like the way they were
presenting it and so i said you know
what
i didn't think there would ever be any
like revenue associated with it but i
said let's have our own youtube channel
so that we can make sure we have like a
good quality copy of the video and that
just kind of
became
what it was and then you know now
everybody has one
no problem i don't even eat the bone
[Music]
yeah no
pretty good
[Music]
oh now it's making yeah now it's yeah
now it's coming through
okay yeah
yeah it's like building delayed yeah
later on it's like getting kicked in the
nuts you know it doesn't hurt right that
second
but the lingerie in the front give it
about 11 seconds and you're gonna be on
the ground plumes a bit of plumes
so i think it's safe to say that you
wouldn't be doing what you're doing now
if not for the inspiration of of living
legends like howard stern and david
letterman and i think if you were to ask
letterman fans what it is about him that
makes him great you get a different
response from everyone that you ask but
i'm curious from your unique perspective
what do you think was his strongest
trait as a talk show host oh
well
i think that
they seem to be doing the show without
any regard for the audience and it
seemed to be like
nobody's watching which was not true
let's do what we think is funny and i
think that's the first time i saw that
on network television you know and they
just do these long weird bits that could
only exist in the middle of the night
and i just remember falling in love with
the show and not mentioning it to
anybody
my tongue's starting numb right now
and um
and uh the first person i mentioned the
show to was my grandfather who was like
80 something at the time i said he said
to me actually do you ever see this guy
letterman i was like
yes i love that guy and that's when i
realized that i loved that guy and then
i think one thing that you and howard
stern have in common is a fascination
and sort of a soft place in your heart
for individuals with very odd
personalities yeah yeah
we're weirdo magnets yeah yeah and what
ways do you think he's influenced you
most as a broadcaster no in huge ways um
i will say the one distinction is howard
has an affinity for those people on the
air i welcome them into my home
he really taught me without expressly
teaching me that the show is what's most
important and i just remember hearing
him one day going on and on about his
brother-in-law and his in-laws visiting
and he was brutal describing it and i
was just thinking like oh this guy has
to go home this guy has to go home his
wife's gonna look that's my brother you
[ __ ] right but it was it was worth it
to him he made that sacrifice for us and
that honesty and really that philosophy
of just
saying whatever
you think you shouldn't say
saying it
i really just went nuts for it
this is the one that's like the prank
right yeah yeah okay
the bomb beyond insanity
oh yeah
my nose is starting to run yeah and
when the sauce gets hot
i'm gonna warn you i get the hiccups so
sometimes i do as well
so maybe we'll start singing back and
forth here
nope no i got the hiccups okay
oh there they are it's like i summoned
them and those are deep
they hit
they're cute too right i'm going to hit
him like a cute huh
oh boy
wow
yeah that's that's hot
yeah
yeah that's the bomb beyond insanity
okay
i'm right with you right with you
i'm still going no milk
i might have to blow my nose a little
bit let the record show before before
your career in hollywood took off how
would you distill the experience of
being a wedding dj is that a lovely
remember we're supposed to ignore the
fact that you're poisoning your guests
you're killing your guests then we're
building our conversation
oh my god
just be careful around your eyes you
know you'll sweat a little don't touch
the eyes like careful around good tip
yeah
uh it's a lot of pressure because if you
screw up you ruin somebody's wedding day
this is hitting me in a big way
but it was fun to do
and if i was somebody who was skilled at
picking up girls it would have been a
great way to pick up girls
what would you say is the number one
guaranteed to get the dance floor
jumping wedding anthem of all time
uh moni money probably is one that cuts
across
all age groups
[Music]
all right jimmy
how you feeling bad yeah yeah
are you ready to move on to the next
very much so
[Music]
i'm drooling and crying at the same time
this is the first
you're like barbara walters you know you
make your guests cry but in a different
way i'll take that i take that as such a
compliment coming from you jimmy
all right so this is hellfire
the crank sauce okay
hellfire
the crank sauce huh
so
it sucks
but i think
coming off the heat of the last one
i don't even know which one is burning
me now because i'm still
buzzing like a
like there's a like a nest of bees in my
mouth right now
they've stung me a thousand times from
the inside
women have lips like kylie jenner at the
end of this
so there's a film that you made that
very few people have heard of but
for my money not being hyperbolic in any
way i think is the funniest movie i've
ever seen in my life and that's windy
city heat oh thank you yeah
and i'm just curious how do you regard
that project like what's the greatest
achievement in my life i mean it's uh
it's a prank that
was going on for 20 years and when
when we made this movie and it's still
going on 20 years later
and there's a guy named perry and it's
almost impossible to explain but
one thing i could tell people before
they watch it is it's 100 real
not a bit of it is
is phony i mean it's all phony in that
everyone is playing a prank on one guy
uh thank you yeah uh that is i i could
watch that movie
seven times a week i ca and and you know
what i'll say is uh you know i could
probably quote the whole thing oh really
and it's one of the it's trouble brewing
you know i got a
city of broken shoulders big dreams
all right well i'm glad to hear that
uh-oh here we go
[Music]
glass dab all right
here we go dabbers
[Music]
i'm gonna put a couple dabs whoa all
right
all right cheers jimmy cheers to you
sean
here we go
[Music]
my sinuses are clear
my lips are on fire
my tonsils will never be the same
and i'm gonna get your phone number so i
can call you i'm in the bathroom tonight
of course i do
a baptism by fire through hot ones but
thankfully jimmy we've reached the
finish line of our spicy meal together
and you're a man of many hidden talents
from clarinet to drawing to pizza making
so we're hoping right here you'll be
generous enough to show off another one
of those hidden talents oh we've brought
you
harmonica oh wow and we're hoping if you
would be so kind to give us a musical
expression of how can i feel my nose
monica sure
beautiful a musical expression of how
you're feeling right now with your mouth
lips and tongue ablaze all right
yeah all right let's see here we go
[Music]
it's hard to play harmonica when your
tongue is
twice its normal size
[Music]
oh my goodness
absolutely beautiful jimmy kimmel
closing it out with the harmonica solo
and now my friend there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you this camera this camera this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life what do i have going on
my life well i'm gonna go to the cedar
sinai hospital
um
i'm gonna get a mouth transplant and uh
no you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
drink some uh what is this came out of a
cow what do they call it a little milk
yeah i'm gonna go home and i'm have a
little milk not right now though because
i want to make sure it's very clear i
drank no milk and no water during this
torture session
let the record show
thank you
[Music]
great job jimmy great job
[Applause]
have you ever had to shoot more than one
show in a day
never more than one in a day but i've
done like i've strung together like
three and three days or like four and
four days before you know and then and
does it ever become very very unpleasant
it could be the said like the same thing
about like uh an nfl linebacker or
something you know like the the physical
toll sacrifice like eating the chicken
wings it can't be worse than that right
so i feel like i can run it out on some
level all right that's a good way of
looking at it that's my compartment
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans i just wanted to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
season 16. we're back and we missed you
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you